d'abord la loi immigration vient d'être
adoptée mais divise les députés de la
majorité oui elle est passée avec 349
voix sur 573 votants dans nos
circonscription sur les h élus
d'indréloire et du Loir etcher 5q ont
voté pour deux contre et une s'est
abstenu une fracture qui se voit au sein
même de la majorité en effet la dernière
version du texte est perçue comme trop
dure par de nombreux députés les
explication de Faustine lunau pour 349
contre 186 l'assemblée nationale a
adopté un texte Durc par son passage en
commission mixte paritaire c'est ce qui
a été adopté lors du vote du projet de
loi sur l'immigration hier cette
dernière version divise dans l'hémicycle
y compris au sein même de la majorité en
témoignne les votes des députés en
indrloire Fabienne kbock du groupe
Renaissance a voté contre elle regrette
un texte trop dur et pas assez tourné
vers l'intégration des personnes
immigrées qu' a des mesures
inconstitutionnelles et enfin des
mesures qui n vont pas du tout qui sont
trop dur qui stigmatisent qui vont
rendre plus les personnes dans la
pauvreté dans la précarité voilà donc
donc il faut être faut prendre ses
responsabilités il faut être sérieux
quoi une trentaine de mesures serait un
constitutionnel une des raisons qui ont
poussé Sabine tiet député démocrate à
s'abstenir elle conteste le processus
législatif une motion de rejet avait été
adoptée avant même le début des débats
sur le premier texte voulait pas aller
contre vote mais je ne voulais pas non
plus voter un texte avec ces
dispositions là qui qui risquent d'être
rétoqué moi en tant que législateur je
dois faire des lois propres j'ai envie
de dire et ne pas laisser au Conseil
constitutionnel le soin de nettoyer un
texte c'est pour ça que j'ai beaucoup
regretté qu'on a pas pu discuter ce
texte avec 349 pour contre 186 contre le
texte a quand même été voté par la
plupart des députés de la majorité c'est
c'est le cas en Loir etcher y compris
pour Christophe Marion député
Renaissance pourtant issu de la gauche
socialiste ce n'est pas du tout le texte
que j'aurais souhaité mais à un moment
je crois qu'il faut prendre ces
responsabilités
dégularisation on ne supprime
pas l'aide médicale d'État on interdit
les CRAT aux mineurs pour moi c'était
quelque chose d'absolument indispensable
donc on a des éléments positifs les
divisions ne touchent pas que
l'assemblée défavorable le ministre de
la Santé Aurélien Rousseau a démissionné
de ses fonctions il est remplacé par
agès firmain le
baudau